the internet with the questions that the
people wrote in lawrence wilkerson does
the Trump administration plan to bypass
Congress to sell arms to Saudi Arabia
concern you very much all bad and if the
Congress really has the courage
political and moral it will pass a
separate piece of legislation and just
disregard the Export Control Act which
would take too long anyway and shut him
down kindly yeah okay John Waters as the
Pope of trash is that a nickname well
that's been called worse yeah yeah can
you confirm that Trump is the trashiest
president of all time oh yeah well I
think he's the worse I think you know I
took three looks like a white James
Brown impersonator now yes
I mean besides him there but also they
take or I mean it looks like Saddam
Hussein's palace house looks like jeff
koons decorated without art history or
irony or any edge okay okay
governor bill weld in the event that you
don't get the Republican nomination will
you back the Democratic nominee for
president in 2020 I'm not sure what I do
you know there may be Justin Amash
hanging out there on the libertarian
ticket hard to say
well not would not support mr. Trump
under any circumstances I love
you wouldn't support Trump but you would
might support a third party candidate or
the Democrat depend on who it was anyone
but Trump you wouldn't do that [ __ ]
right in Mickey Mouse thing wouldn't go
back to libertarian aren Alfred he knew
MIT well you people do that I think it's
somebody Newman but he did run for
president in the old days for mad mad
got a real person I know but remember
make of Trump called mayor Pete Alfred E
Newman didn't know yet yes what was the
Democratic National Committee wrong to
implement stricter fundraising and
polling benchmarks for the third round
of debates wait what happened they said
- you need two percent in the polls in
130,000 they're set for the first one
this is to narrow the set for the first
debate numbers to set this is a higher
standard
you can't have more than 20 right is
that the thing there's 23 candidates but
I think with musical chairs breathing
we're not gonna get the chair I think
what they realized was that the
standards that they set were too easy
and so that's why we have so many people
now that are gonna be running and and so
to make it 2 percent instead of 1% it's
gonna maybe now I mean even 10 remember
this with the Republicans it's it's very
hard to to make a mark I don't know how
I guess that's what they'll all do and
that's why it's bad to have so many
because they don't really concentrate
and they destroy other they did evening
these ridiculous emselves from the pack
yes okay should president Trump's plan
to switch to a merit-based immigration
system receive more consideration well
it would be more like what Canada has no
we're not you can have both you can have
you can have merit-based like we do if
you need a but you need some engineers
right you'll get some visas for them but
really this country is based on having
people come over here not based on
having
a PhD or high-level skills I mean I
don't know what your family did when
they came here my family worked in coal
mines you know and that's what most
that's what most people's family did and
so I think even when we say merit base
it sort of suggests that someone who
only has a you know doesn't have a high
education doesn't have merit right
what's merit is merit you know I think
that we need people who are you know who
are unskilled laborers we need them just
as much as we need people who are
engineers so I would descend on that I
think the latest proposal is worth some
fleshing out yeah it's it's more normal
Republican the one that was ignored two
weeks ago that he put forth I hate to be
called a normal Republican no no I mean
I'm talking about Trump his proposal
today he was like I'm gonna stop
immigration with tariffs that's crazy
that's crazy right but like I can
understand how that side looks at what
happened two weeks ago and what oh you
know what if you're not gonna like even
engage on the semi-normal a proposal
let's just go back to crazy yeah but
it's it's more of his trying to keep
people from the so-called [ __ ]
countries out I mean I think in their
almost giving him too much credit
you know it's it's the idea that like he
his motivation is to keep people out
have you noticed recently they've been a
lot of people taking out ads let's pray
for the president even Nancy Pelosi said
there's a whole day of it yeah that's
because they're afraid he's losing it
that's why yeah I'm sure they are okay
finally what do you think about
Elizabeth Warren's proposal to change
Justice Department policy on whether a
sitting president can be indicted yes
always Elizabeth Warren who actually
comes up with the oh not just don't ever
set a funny thing in her life she's a
real laugh riot right little human no I
don't want somebody coming out today and
I agree because I made a joke if you
didn't like it I think she's not funny -
you don't to be funny but it is
important ever sent to you we know if he
doesn't have one but you know that's not
a reason to know we don't
hell no I think I think the founders
were smart when they put a little
ambiguity in the Constitution look a lot
more than a little but write it let's
modern modern people men things a little
bit but one of the things in the
Constitution in Section four of Article
two that deals with impeachment and the
words that are around it says you
shouldn't let lower politics be used to
remove a sitting president I think
that's sound advice the kind of politics
you have to use to remove a sitting
president is the Senate the Supreme
Court the house and impeachment and
that's the way it should be done now
after cog continuation of a government
deliberations and 9/11 and our thought
that maybe we'd lose a third of the
government in one terrorist attack we
designed some other ways to deal with it
but that's in extremist conditions I
think the Constitution is pretty sound
the president should be removed from
office by impeachment and we ought to
have some congressmen with some balls
all right
[Applause]
you